哈囉大家好歡迎來到中木資放心說
我是周慕姿心理師
今天要跟大家分享的單元是放心來信
我們要分享的內容主題是
想獲得控制感並且更認識自己的情緒
所以我們選了四位朋友
來跟我們分享關於他們的來信
首先第一位是匿名
他說老師好 很喜歡收聽老師的節目
總是得到很多啟發跟安慰
謝謝老師一直用溫暖的聲音跟話語
陪伴聽眾
我有一個困擾的問題
那就是我在跟親人吵架時
只要對方對我大聲吼叫
或即使沒有大聲
但讓我感覺到不舒服的時候
我就會不由自主的掉眼淚
我當下的情緒不是懶過
我不知道為什麼自己會哭出來
我感覺應該是憤怒的
想要好好把自己的想法說出來
但因為哭我就無法思考
並且覺得自己很軟弱無助
請問老師
老師 我到底該怎麼做
才能在吵架的時候
好好表達我的情緒跟想法
不要哭出來呢
這位匿名你在分享這個東西
非常非常重要
我假設你有可能是女性
原因是因為在我們的社會文化裡面
限制我們情緒的展現
例如說 有些男性在他受傷的時候
在他覺得很挫折的時候
他的反應居然是發怒
他可能會就是大罵別人
甚至可能會攻擊別人
可是有些女性
他在他很生氣的時候
表現出來的居然是哭
因為對他來說
要去對別人表現憤怒這件事情
這個有攻擊性的情緒
在他從小的生長過程中
是不被允許的
或是這個社會不允許他
因此他很習慣用委屈跟哭的方式
讓自己的情緒可以獲得一個
一個抒發跟展現
但是如果你在那一個當下
我在猜你最容易出現的情緒
也可能是委屈
但委屈基本來說就是憤怒的一種
因為當我今天憤怒的時候
我不能表現出來
他就會變成委屈
因為我被不公平對待
無緣無故被兇
因為我被誤解
我對這件事情感到憤怒
可是我又不能覺得自己是可以憤怒的
所以我很容易用委屈
這個方式 那委屈就會讓我們想哭嘛
哭就讓我覺得無能
它就是一個非常正常的一個情緒表現喔
所以我覺得你問得很棒就是
我應該要怎麼做才可以在吵架的時候
好好表達我的情緒跟想法
不要哭出來呢
這個當然是有步驟的調整的
當然你有很多可能性因此
我只是簡單給一些分享
也許你可以參考看看
而最主要如果你發現這件事情
真的有一點困難性的話
去找專業的人員去協助你
讓你慢慢釐清你的情緒
並且訓練自己有步驟的去表達自己
這也是很好的方法喔
首先是這樣子
那就是先讓你自己有辦法
在對方對你吵架的時候
先不要馬上哭出來
我們的第一個目標是什麼
所以重點不是先表達
重點就是
先讓你可以離他的情緒遠一點
你就不會哭嘛
遇到他的情緒的時候要你不哭
不是的
因為你可能覺得很害怕
有可能對方真的每次對你生氣吵架的時候
都會往你的痛處打
所以你才會這麼難過
這些事情都有可能發生
所以在最好的情況之下
能夠讓你離對方的怒氣遠一點
讓你不要馬上承接對方的情緒
這個是最好的方式
所以讓自己可以離開現場
讓自己緩一下 一感覺到自己的情緒
被對方就是影響的時候
就讓你自己可以往後退
甚至離開現場
這是最好的方式
接下來在你離開之後
問問你自己
他剛剛說的那些話做的那些事
對我的情緒影響是什麼
為什麼我會產生想哭的情緒
是因為他誤解我嗎
是因為我覺得我沒有辦法
為自己說話嗎
是因為我覺得他說的
我就要去解釋
因為好像他說的就是對的嗎
你要開始去想
那就是對方如果可以說什麼東西
馬上引發你的情緒反應
那代表著你的情緒的確很容易
受對方的影響
那我們要思考的就會是會不會
在我和他之間
權力不對等的狀況已經很久了
所以我覺得這些東西都是幫助你去檢視
是不是這些權力不對等的狀況
讓你會覺得當他一說你什麼你就沒辦法回
然後你就會覺得很委屈
這些東西都是很值得去探討的哦
所以我會蠻鼓勵你去思考看看
這個部分如何先讓自己的情緒不那麼容易被別人影響
再來練習在發生這樣的事情
之後先讓自己緩一下
然後思考這件事情對自己的影響
還有我跟他表達我要達到的目的是什麼
然後練習表達
這個是可以練習看看的事情
再來第二位一樣是匿名
前陣子很多我很深刻意識到自己
被社群資訊影響很多
他們在社群上展現很多很美好的樣子
讓當時狀況就已經不佳的自己
陷入更深的自卑
但最近有一天我也發現
雖然社群有這些令人內耗的資訊
但我也確實在社群上
找到很多幫助自己走出困境等療癒的媒體
例如也是在這樣的社群平台
我才認識周慕姿心理師
及更多心理師的分享
所以該怎麼說呢
我們要有足夠健康的心理狀態
才可以在這片網路的洪流裡
辨別好壞嗎
好 這位匿名你的觀察
非常非常的仔細喔
我覺得現在特別是脆
我不知道各位在用就是社群平台
你覺得最容易影響你心情是什麼
對我來說最容易影響我心情的其實是脆
我曾經有一段時間
因為我前陣子去郵輪 大家知道我很開心
我那段時間因為郵輪的網路
本來就不是很好
所以我幾乎是完全斷網的情況
我發現我那一個多禮拜睡得非常好
狀況非常好 人生變得非常開闊
每天都沒有什麼煩惱的事情
所以我覺得這個是一個比較特別的地方
那就是所以它是一個非常
客製化的一個社群平台
因此它會在你曾經看過
你只要在這一篇文章稍微流連一下
你甚至沒按讚
他就會一直大量的推播
相關的資訊的東西給你
如果你不小心看的是例如說對別人很美好
然後很正向的東西
然後就會很大量這些東西
又或者你如果剛好看到的是某個
可能是社會新聞
你也會看到大量有關那一種主題
的社會新聞
你就會覺得天啊人生也太悲哀了
為什麼有那麼多就是難受的事情
於是你心情就受影響
沒有錯
媒體試讀是我們現在在社群平台
非常需要做的事情
以及呢 要怎麼樣讓自己可以離開這個平台
不要把它變成我自己生活的一部分
非常非常的重要
那我很開心聽到你說 你有分辨
有時候會看到那樣子的訊息
但有時候又可以看到對自己有幫助的訊息
所以我個人覺得讓自己可以
更主動的去選擇
某些比較開心的
就是讓你自己覺得生活比較積極的訊息
而減少去看那些會影響你心情的訊息
是非常重要的
因為社群平台就是一個要我們把注意力
放在別人的生活上的一個主要的一個媒體
它的目的就是這個
所以就算你今天是看別人回應你
那還是在別人
你不會想說如果今天你寫一篇文章
出去人家看不看都無所謂
你就寫日記就好
你幹嘛寫在社群媒體咧對不對
所以基本來說社群平台它的目的就是要你
一直去看別人到底
怎麼想你別人怎麼過他的生活
別人他給你什麼好東西
別人他拿出什麼好玩的事情
而這件事情對我們
如果已經是花太多時間
在別人身上刺激太多
以至於我很容易焦慮
我的多巴胺常常過度
就是常常過度耗損
以至於到最後我連自己生活中都覺得
我好像覺得什麼東西都沒有
就是一點都不有趣
我只剩下力氣就是一直滑那個
什麼抖音啊
小短影片啊等等
你說會發現這其實就是一個多巴胺中毒的狀態
所以讓自己去選擇資訊
讓自己可以稍微好一些
這些東西就是一個非常非常好的
有意志的
對於前額葉來說是一件很棒的選擇
所以你這樣子的觀察非常好喔
所以給你一個肯定
接下來是Jimmy他說
周老師你好
我覺得我是所謂的秩序敏感者
當事情不按照自己規劃設想的進行
就會焦慮不安
或者當伴侶沒有在自己覺得
對方應該要覺察自己的軟弱
來主動關心自己時就會生氣
該怎麼樣做改變這個狀況呢
好 關於Jimmy
我覺得你說了一個很棒的東西
你對自己有個覺察
那就是如果事情不按照你的方式去想
或是別人讓你失望
你就會很容易有很多的情緒
因此這件事情既然你有這個覺察
我會更鼓勵你在往下想一點
因為你的狀態就有點像是
我在內耗課程中裡面講的控制型
也就是你會很希望事情
可以按照你的方式去做
別人的反應是你想要的
如果沒有這樣
可能就會覺得不安
因此去了解到如果事情沒有按照
你想像的你出現的情緒是什麼
為什麼這樣會讓你不安呢
那是因為結果你不能處理
還是這會對你產生什麼樣的影響
甚至這會影響你對自己的看法是什麼
我想必須要深入的去摸索這些事情
你才能更能了解這些東西
對你的意義是什麼
這也很鼓勵你可以去練習做一些自我覺察
也許你會看見一些沒注意到的東西
最後一則也是匿名
今天充滿了各種匿名的朋友
好的
心理師你好
我對心理學一直很有興趣
也明白自我覺察的重要性
平常我會透過思考和書寫等方式
練習整理自己的內在狀態
但我發現
身邊有些朋友不太理解這樣的我
他們認為過去的事情就應該讓他過去
沒必要探究或梳理自我感受
他們也覺得人應該保持正向思考就好
這樣的觀點差異
讓我有時在對話中感覺頻率對不上
我開始好奇
有些人一生從不進行自我探索
似乎也能過得很好
那人為什麼要梳理過去的問題和
探索內在呢
會不會像他們說的一樣是徒增煩惱
好的 匿名我覺得你問得非常好
這件事情也是我在心理諮商
就是心理衛生推廣
不停提醒大家的事情
我們有沒有要處理自己全部的議題
有沒有一定要探索全部的過去的傷痕
有沒有一定要解決過去所有的困難
沒有啊 你有需要你就直接解決
你需要的 所以我完全同意你現在的觀察
那就是 你說的沒有錯
有些人他不用去靠梳理過去的一些經驗
或者是他現在的一些感受
他一樣可以過得很好
他可以靠前進
他可以靠接下來的注意力是什麼
用很正向的方式
正向心理學的方式
目標導向的方式去過生活
他過得很好
這樣非常好啊
但也有一些人他用這一套是沒有辦法的
他忍不住會去想
為什麼我會這麼做
為什麼我會這麼想
為什麼我會這樣思考
於是他沒有辦法靠
我都不要想就做就好了 他忍不住回頭
為甚麼會做出這樣的選擇
因此他會走另外一條路
這也是非常正常的
回到我們諮商學派
我們諮商學派也有很多種
有一些就是精神分析
精神分析就是像佛洛伊德
像榮格這種大家很常聽到的
他們就很在意潛意識
認為潛意識對我們人的影響非常非常大
所以包含夢啊
包含你那些沒有意識到的人
然後不小心脫口而出的佛洛伊德式錯誤
然後這些所有的投射啊等等的
他們會很在乎這些東西對你的影響
但是有一些後現代的心理諮商學派
他們甚至不在乎過往經驗對你的影響
雖然我們在講阿德勒會講到早年經驗
我們在講完形也會講到
你過去沒有處理好的情緒
叫做「未盡事宜」 這件事情可能會影響你
但最終誠實的說這些東西都是選擇
選擇是什麼意思 如果這件事情他會影響你
你覺得這個學派適合你
你就會用這個學派去做
如果你很在乎潛意識對你的影響
你就會用潛意識的學派去工作
可是如果今天
你根本不在乎過去對你的影響
也有所謂的短期治療
他幾乎只看你接下來要做的事情
但不考慮過去的影響
這些東西全部都是選擇
因此 有沒有哪一個東西是放諸四海皆準的
我沒有覺得
人就是一個這麼複雜的動物
所以所有的人都會有自己適合的
跟不適合的東西
有他面對生活面對生命面對困境
自己的選擇
因此我覺得你的觀察非常好
有些人可以這樣有些人不行
而你呢你可以怎麼樣
怎麼樣是你選擇的部分呢
就像我自己所工作的狀態
進行一些行動的時候
背後的一些理由是什麼
可是像我先生他完全不是學這個的
他對這個部分可能就沒有這麼多想法
而這樣你們能不能相處呢
只要你覺得能相處
那就可以相處啊
因為本來人跟人之間
就不會有觀念一模一樣的
所以找到屬於你舒服的方式
做你自己覺得適當的探索
沒有好壞沒有對錯
只有你想要什麼
這個部分是我想分享給你的哦
好的
那麼今天四則放心來信
希望對大家有一點幫助喔
那麼 周慕姿放心說
我們下次見囉 掰掰